♪ ♪
- Tim, back at the studio,
I came.
- Cool.
- I mean, there's
a chemistry there.
I can't explain it.
- Yeah.
- I mean, Shannon's so nice.
- So nice.
- Tim, I don't know what to do.
- I think you should do...
whatever it is
you're about to do.
- Break up with her?
- Maybe. I mean...
As long as you get to hit
them skins one last time.
- Oh, Tim, come on.
What are you doing?
Don't talk like that.
- I don't know.
It's this hat.
It's changing me.
- Throw it out.
- I tried.
- ♪ Sweet chariot ♪
♪ Comin' for to carry me... ♪
Hey, babe.
- Hey, Shannon.
- What's wrong?
- I don't think
this is working.
- What? [chuckles]
This is coming
out of nowhere.
Is there something
wrong with the song?
- No, uh... well,
we did have to re-record
the song with Molly.
But it's only because the--
the client thought there
was no spark in ours,
which is kind of my point.
There's, like,
no spark here.
- What are you gonna do?
Spend the rest of your life
hanging out with Tim
telling vulgar high school
stories about your ass
and your testicles?
- Whoa. Whoa, whoa, whoa.
I never said my balls
came out, okay?
I mean, they did.
Got a huge laugh.
Look, Shannon,
you're perfect.
But we're not perfect
for each other.
And I don't think either of us
should settle
for anything less.
[reflective music]
♪ ♪
- Sam...
I just want you to know
that I never felt
like I was settling.
- I did.
I--I felt like I was settling.
- Damn it, Sam.
- Oh, sorry.
S--ah, oof.
No, I'm sorry.
- [sputters]
- Love you.
Oh, I'm s--
I'm sorry.